we're learning to young mothers from two
different states died soon after getting
the flu
Tandy Harmon from Oregon and Karly ilk
Slavin from Indiana were both mothers of
two their family said they were healthy
adults the Centers for Disease Control
and Prevention says the number of states
with high levels of flu activity jumped
from nine on December 16th to 32 on
January 13th Manuel Bojorquez is at the
Palm Beach Gardens Medical Center in
Florida where flu patients are
stretching resources many good morning
good morning this aggressive flu season
is causing problems all around the
country hospitals like this one have
been inundated and some doctors say the
medicine used to treat the flu is
becoming harder to find in some spots
here they've even set up beds in
conference rooms to accommodate all the
new patients this is probably the worst
flu season I've seen in the last ten
years
dr. Jamie snorky says the volume of new
flu patients has put the Palm Beach
Gardens Medical Center at full capacity
for some reason these strains are
hitting young healthy people a little
bit harder than in past years and I'm
not quite sure we know why that is yet
just last week the state saw 52 new
community outbreaks bringing the
seasonal total to 159 the highest in
nearly a decade
but according to federal health
officials Florida is not even among the
24 states seeing the highest level of
viral activity still parts of the
Sunshine State are struggling to treat
the virus some pharmacies have been
running low on the medication Tamiflu
pediatrician saat Verde says despite the
shortage there are other options the
preferred route I would say would be
vaccinations and we have plenty of
vaccine supply three children have died
from the flu in Florida none was
vaccinated 12 year old Dylan Winnick
died Tuesday his stepfather mike says
the family is stunned by how quickly the
virus took him no indications no
warnings just a
just common cold that's what's so scary
about it in one Florida school district
20% of students are out sick so classes
were canceled today so workers could
scrub down the campuses Gail I gotta
take it very seriously thank you very
much Manny